this episode was made possible by
generous supporters on patreon hey
crazies I've made a particular statement
several times in this channel light is
an electromagnetic wave a disturbance in
electric and magnetic fields which begs
the question huh what what does it even
mean well let's start from the beginning
no no no stop that we've talked about
this stupid AI I mean from the beginning
of our most recent series on
electrodynamics whenever it's possible
we try to treat the electric and
magnetic stuff separately if there's a
charge there's an electric field if that
charge is moving there's also a magnetic
field that's two separate fields the
electric field and the magnetic field
and people spent the majority of the
1800s trying to describe how they work
to the time line in 1835 Gauss's law
showed us electric fields came from
charges in 1820 and pierrez law showed
us magnetic fields came from moving
charges both confirming what we covered
earlier bingo bango mystery souls fields
described and his story wait a minute
that can't be the whole story right I
mean we've seen other laws in this
series there was a Gauss's law for
magnetism - and in 1831 we got something
called Faraday's law that brings the
equation count up - for each of these
laws says something about at least one
of these fields Gauss's law for
electricity says electric fields point
away from positive charges and toward
negative charges Gauss's law for
magnetism says magnetic fields always
form closed loops and pierrez law says
those closed loops wrap around a moving
charge Faraday's law is the odd one out
on this list it seems to connect the
fields to each other basically a
changing magnetic field makes an
electric field wait wait one of the
fields can make the other field yeah
it's pretty weird isn't it come to think
of it this is kind of a big deal if one
field can make the other field then
maybe the charges don't make the fields
at all maybe they just affect them maybe
they're a thing all by themselves I mean
we said light was a disturbance in
electric and magnetic fields and light
is a thing all by itself so it makes
sense
in fact that's exactly how we imagine
fields these days notice the arrows in
this graphic remain in place as the
charge moves they're attached to the
space not the charge if there aren't any
charges around we like to imagine the
fields are still there and just have a
value of zero we really wouldn't get
confirmation of this though until the
1860s back to the time line thirty years
after Faraday James Clerk Maxwell
interest the conversation he thought to
himself but changing magnetic you can
affect the electric dude even a Tsar
changing electric boobs affect the
magnetic field yes to affect each other
so we took amperes law and tacked on an
extra term to make it happen did he just
invent that out of thin air no not
really I'm lying a little bit he wasn't
that haphazard about it he did imagine a
conceptual model first with a sea of
tiny molecular vortices that model was
horribly wrong but his result turned out
to be correct anyway that lucky son of a
anyway
Faraday said that a changing magnetic
field gives us an electric field and now
Maxwell's saying that a changing
electric field gives us a magnetic field
the circle is now complete this
discovery had profound consequences for
our understanding of these two fields
but Maxwell kind of fell short in this
department
his versions of the equations were kind
of a mess there were literally 20 of
them with vector calculus we can combine
some to shorten the list to eight which
makes amperes law a little more obvious
but Maxwell wasn't interested in being
concise he was an experimentalist and it
wasn't super great at deep truths it
wouldn't be until Oliver Heaviside
arrived twenty years later that we
actually get the equations everyone
knows and yet somehow these equations
are called Maxwell's equations
history is a cold-hearted monster anyway
that the point is we've described a way
for these two fields to affect each
other back to the time line
Maxwell thought about this connection
for a few more years then suddenly
something occurred to him my childhood
he gives us a magnetic field the
childhood kiddie basta together a
changing magnetic field
that's when Maxwell saw the light like
literally he rediscovered light we know
from Faraday a changing magnetic field
gives us an electric field if that
electric field is also changing then we
get a magnetic field a changing magnetic
field which gives us a changing electric
field that gives us a changing magnetic
field that gives us a you get the point
Maxwell had discovered electromagnetic
waves and when he calculated the speed
of those waves he found it to be a
constant 299,792,458 m/s the speed of
light and it's not just about light
that's the speed in which any change
happening with the charge can be
communicated to the field there's a
delay between when the charge moves and
how the field responds at all these
points in space it's difficult to see
with this graphic though because
everything is happening so fast
we need to zoom way out and slow the
speed of light way down to get a better
view let's imagine a radio transmission
tower inside the tower charges move up
and down since that's a type of
acceleration the magnetic field is
changing over time the field arrows
nearby respond almost immediately but
the ones farther away don't respond
until later the speed of light demands
that there be a delay in a way the field
arrows are responding to where the
charge was in the past and what it was
doing back then rather than where it is
and what it's doing now the result is a
wave patterns which we usually write
using sines or cosines we just evaluate
each arrow in the field at an earlier
time depending on how far away it is
from the source that's why we get this
extra term but math aside let's just
stop and appreciate something for a few
seconds this field disturbance is
self-sustaining you can stop the charge
from moving and the fields will continue
to do this there's now a disturbance in
a couple fields that travels out through
space all because some charge
accelerated at some point in the past
and that field disturbance is what we
call light so have you seen the light
let us know in the comments thanks for
liking and sharing this video don't
forget to subscribe if you'd like to
keep up with us and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
several of you asked about the James
Webb Space Telescope in the comments yes
the JWST will be located at Earth's l2
point when it's fully operational if
it's that far away from Earth though we
have to make sure it works perfectly
before we launch because we can't fix it
once it's out there anyway thanks for
watching